the biggest misconception about you i
think is because you're so ridiculously
gorgeous
that people don't understand how
brilliant a student you were you were
the valedictorian of your school i was
yeah and and not only that you got a
full scholarship i believe to
northwestern yes which is an incredible
college i i got a scholarship in
engineering and they said you have to
pick one and there was like chemical
engineer electrical
when i found another one i was like well
i like chemistry i'm good at that and
i'll i'll figure it out but then i
right when i went to college it was kind
of the first time i had to really work
hard at school i mean i was a good
student and then college is like the
next level of that
and i started working a lot and i just
felt really like i couldn't do both well
so after one semester i dropped out when
someone who looks like you is sitting
there in a room with people majoring in
chemical engineering
i mean let l you can be
i know you want to be moderated
like i mean
are people driven to distraction by you
walking in a room i mean you are
stunning and you know that and you don't
get paid the kind of money you paid
i mean what what is that like
well i was just starting to model so i
don't i don't think i got really any
more attention than any freshman on
campus gets a lot of attention because
from the guys but i will say
i did stick out in some of the chemical
engineering type classes
and my one professor
said to me the first day i think you're
in the wrong class honey right now
you've been a victim of that stereotype
yes because didn't the professor also
accuse you of cheating because you aced
the exam in some in physics or something
calculated calculus i mean
right but you took a calculus exam and
you got very high scores
and i had missed the final so i had to
like do it on another day and he thought
i had gotten the test from someone
because you're good-looking
the professor accused you of cheating
yeah it actually was kind of eye-opening
because i feel like my generation of
women we didn't feel like
i grew up with era and i felt like i
could be the first woman president or
whatever i wanted to be and then that
was the first time i actually saw that
looking a certain way
can be could be a negative and that
people were going to judge me right a
certain way based on the way i look but
you've used it to your advantage you've
even said in business deals where you
sit down you play
the idiot the dumb model because it it
somehow sets you up in an advantage you
can sit there and listen to them
quietly
where they think they know everything
and what are you doing assessing them
and saying [ __ ] i'm 10 times more
intelligent than this idiot well i've
actually learned a lot from sitting in
those meetings but yeah sometimes you
can just
you you i don't have to walk in with all
the answers no one expects that out of
me so then i can i can bide my time and
gather my information before i make a
decision but i've also done it even with
photographers when they asked me to do
like crazy things i'm like
gosh i don't understand what you're
saying will you just show me how to do
that will you show me how to go on a
surfboard and not get my hair wet in
high heels
and then they're like oh forget it we'll
destroy it on the beach and i'm like
okay because you know they ask you to do
crazy things that no one could ever do
was your iq ever tested do you think so
would you would you ever want were you
curious about how intelligent you were
no because i i like the idea that it's
really
right exactly